>> Tom Gjelten: Hello
everyone, I'm Tom Gjelten.
I'm a correspondent
for NPR, which is one
of the media partners.
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
Thank you to the
Library of Congress
for doing this every year.
It's always, to me, one of the
highlights of the year here
in Washington D.C. And
we're really thrilled,
and I'm personally really
thrilled to be a part of this.
And I'm especially
delighted today
because these are
two fabulous books.
And I'm glad to see
you all here.
You've already had your
signings I guess right?
>> Alfredo Corchado: Yes.
>> Tom Gjelten: But I'm
guessing that if any
of you didn't get a chance
to get them signed before
you can probably catch
him afterwards.
They're really terrific books.
Alfredo Corchado, Homelands.
Four friends, two
countries and the fate
of the great Mexican/American
migration.
And Francisco Cantu, The
Line Becomes a River,
Dispatches From the Border.
I loved these, both
of these books.
Both of them are
beautifully written,
profoundly personal and intuit.
And I would say both
qualify as memoirs
and you know both
Mexican American
with Mexican American
heritage and you both write
from the vantage point
of that experience.
Have you read each
other's books?
>> Francisco Cantu: Yes.
[ Laughter ]
>> Alfredo Corchado:
I gave him a blurb.
>> Tom Gjelten: I know
you gave him a blurb.
And I'm glad that you read it
before you gave him a blurb.
But we can have a three
way conversation then
since you're familiar with
each other's writings.
So I say they're both memoirs
written both in first person.
But in each case, each of these
books tells a larger story,
aside from the personal
narrative.
And in both cases
really important
and timely stories right now.
Both in a very general
sense about the border,
and that's I think the title
of this presentation
this afternoon.
But in different ways.
And I'm going to just briefly
give you a couple thoughts,
my own thoughts about
each of these books
to sort of start it off.
Alfredo, you're a journalist
and you write both as a migrant,
as a Mexican American but you
also write as a journalist.
And we're talking before, I
think our paths probably crossed
because I lived and covered
Mexico back in the 80's
and you were there as well.
And I think we've met
here in Washington D.C.
So Alfredo's book is largely
about the migration experience,
and what it means to
be Mexican American.
You spent much of your life
living along the border.
But you also say that you live
on the border not just literally
but sort of figuratively.
And reading your book I
was reminded of a book by -
another great book by a
Cuban American writer Gustavo
Perez Firmat.
It's called Life on the Hyphen.
And the title of that
book sort of, to me,
is exactly what you're
writing about too.
What it is like to live
on the hyphen of a -
with binational kind
of heritage.
And I recall from your book
a conversation you had,
so Alfredo can tell
you about this,
but there are four friends,
four Mexican American friends
that sort of come
together in Philadelphia.
One of them is an older friend
of yours Primo, more
of an activist.
And at one point in your book
you talk about him asking you
which side are you on?
Where is your homeland?
And do you remember
what you said?
>> Alfredo Corchado:
Yes I said it depends -
if I'm watching a soccer game
between the United States
and Mexico I'm rooting
for whoever is behind.
>> Tom Gjelten: That's
right, but then you say,
I push the conversation aside
because at times I really
have no clue how to answer.
>> Alfredo Corchado:
Right, right.
>> Tom Gjelten: Which I think
was just a story that sort
of goes to your experience
of what it's like to sort
of have those kind of
conflicting identities.
And you can say as we get into
this whether you regard them
as conflicting or complementary.
But you do have sort of a
dual aspect to your identity,
which is - Alfredo's book
is very much about sort
of his own experience with
discovering his identity.
Francisco, you also
write about the border
but whereas I was saying
with Alfredo the border is
as much a figurative
thing as a literal thing.
For you it's very
much a literal thing.
Your experience of the border
is a very physical place.
You write about its
geography, about its history.
It's not so much, it seems
to me in your view something
that can be straddled the way
that Alfredo has straddled
the border figuratively
and literally.
You write really about
the border as something
that separates and
something that is enforced,
that is crossed only
with difficulty.
Those of you who know
the background here,
know that Francisco
spent four years
as an agent of the
border patrol.
So firsthand experience
in that sense.
But then in the last part of
your book and you write a lot
about what it was
like, your experience
as a border patrol agent.
But in the last part of your
book you actually write sort
of in the sense of an advocate,
at least in a personal way
for people who are migrating.
So that's as much as I'm
going to give away for now
about these two books.
We're going to have a good
conversation and you know if -
I'll pause let's say about
15 minutes before the end
to see how much interest
there is on your part,
if you kind of want to get
into the conversation or not.
We have a lot to talk about so I
can't promise I'm going to give
up the floor, but if
you insist we can.
So let's talk first a little bit
about your personal histories.
Alfredo you were born in Mexico.
Give us the first 15 years
of your life let's say.
>> Alfredo Corchado: I was born
in a town called San
Luis Cordero Durango,
which is in Northern Mexico.
My father was a bracero
worker, a guest worker.
And I felt like back then I had
the most idyllic perfect life,
you know?
My father would send
money every two weeks,
we had a little grocery
store in Durango.
And part of my job was to make
sure that every toy worked
that my mother would sell.
So that was - that
was my life, you know?
And I think for a lot of kids
back then we had parents living
in the United States.
You were able to hear
about the United States,
but it wasn't something
that you at least at my age,
that I longed to go
to to be a part of.
Obviously in 1965 we can
talk about that later,
but in 1965 comes around
and changes our entire life.
>> Tom Gjelten: A law that
really opened Americas doors
to immigrants of color
for the first time.
>> Alfredo Corchado:
And my father's boss every
Christmas he would dread the
Christmas vacation because
he thought this guy is
such a great worker that
he may not come back
to - after the holidays.
So after '65 we were able to
become legal, legal immigrants.
And first 10 years of my
life was in the California,
in the Central Valley,
the San Joaquin Valley.
We were farm workers.
My mother and father
worked for the UFW.
Cesar Chavez was the leader
and that was really the
first part of my life.
I quickly assimilated and
learned to speak English
with the help of the song
Ben by Michael Jackson,
and I Think I Love You
by the Partridge Family.
That's how I tasted
the U.S. assimilation.
And never thought - I mean I
never thought I would amount
to much.
But my parents had I think
from the moment they decided
to sacrifice their life,
they thought that you come
to this country, you come
to reinvent yourself.
And when I - I told
them one day, I said,
"I'm going to drop
out of school."
Or I didn't even tell
them, I just did it.
And that was like
their life had ended.
But I ended up going back
to school, community college
and became a journalist.
Mainly because there was one
afternoon where a TV crew went
up to the fields and they
were interviewing people.
And they were looking
for underage workers.
And you were considered
under age
if you were below the age of 15.
So my mother was always
telling me "Pretend
like you're 15" big
hat, shirt and so forth.
And this crew came up
to me, interviewed me
and the first question
out of their mouth
was "How old are you?"
And I said, "13";
so that was it.
I did the reporters job and I
did it pretty easy for them.
>> Tom Gjelten: You grew up
in poverty would you say?
>> Alfredo Corchado:
Yeah I mean we -
>> Tom Gjelten: Talk about
where you lived in California
when you first moved there?
>> Alfredo Corchado:
Sure, my dad -
we didn't even know
we had a father.
I didn't even know his name
because he was always
going back and forth.
This was a time in America where
you had a circle of migration.
Where people would work eight,
nine months out of the year.
And then when we decided
that we were going
to all leave, we
were heartbroken.
And he sent us one of the most
touching moments of my life
with my dad was he sent us a
postcard of the state capital.
And we're leaving, we're
on the Greyhound bus.
I'm the oldest of
four at the time.
And every town that
we stopped in,
my brother would say
"Are we there yet?"
And I would take out
the card and I would go,
"No, we're not there yet."
We ended up in a trailer
house for migrant workers
where sometimes - it
was a very tiny place.
My uncle slept outside with us -
>> Tom Gjelten: Outside.
>> Alfredo Corchado: Outside.
You had - at times you had rats.
It depended on the
crop that was there.
Melons for some reason tended
to attract a lot of those.
And that's really
how our life began.
I mean it was trailer house
and slowly things get better.
The housing got better, the
working conditions got better.
>> Tom Gjelten: And
Francisco tell us
about your upbringing
in Arizona.
>> Francisco Cantu: Yeah
so I grew up in Arizona.
I grew up in a town four or
five hours from the border.
So what's interesting
about that is
that you know the border is
not a totally abstract thing,
like I think it is in a lot
of places in the country.
But it's also not immediate,
it's not in your backyard.
And my mother was born
to Mexican father,
so migrant father,
came up during the time
of the Mexican Revolution.
And they came as refugees
fleeing the violence
of the revolution
from Monterrey, Leon.
But my mom was sort of you
know, her parents split
when she was very young,
so she didn't really grow
up with the Mexican
side of the family.
And so she didn't grow
up speaking Spanish.
I didn't grow up
speaking Spanish.
I didn't grow up with
my Mexican grandparents.
I remember you know,
visiting him.
So I think a lot
of people who grow
up in this country,
I'm third generation.
And you know my entire identity
was as this American kid,
but I had this funny name.
Like my - I go by Paco
and so everybody -
that was the one
thing that made -
that sort of tied
me to my identity.
And -
>> Tom Gjelten: Your mother
couldn't name you Frank
or Francis, but she
named you Francisco.
>> Francisco Cantu: Right,
and it was interesting
because in school I didn't
really become conscious
of the fact that
my name was weird,
or that I had this other
identity until I became older.
And then you know, I remember
sort of my step dad explaining
to me he was like "You
probably need to learn Spanish".
It was like I was in high
school and you could take French
or Spanish and he's like
"You better take Spanish".
And then he explained to me,
people are going to expect -
it was interesting
moment where he was like
"Here's what people are
going to expect from you."
You grow up in Arizona, you
know you have this name.
And so then that sort of became
a different awakening for me.
Like I studied abroad in Mexico.
I began to study
international relations
when I went away to college.
I went to school here
at American university.
And when I started
working in high school,
my first job was as a bus boy.
And all of the people
in the kitchen were
from the same town
in [Inaudible].
And I began, I had
begun learning Spanish
and so I was speaking
Spanish with them.
And the first time I traveled
to Mexico I went to this town
where they were all from - and
they had kind of called their -
they called their brother and
let them know that I was coming.
And he was getting
married that weekend,
so I got invited to his wedding.
And all of a sudden I'm - you
know I arrived in this town,
2,000 miles away in Central
Mexico and people knew who I was
and they knew where I
was from because they're
such a community, you know
a cross border community.
A lot of people had been
deported from Arizona.
They had worked in the same
restaurant where I worked.
And so that was this moment as a
young man where I realized sort
of how - how significant
and insignificant the border
can be simultaneously.
>> Tom Gjelten: Well and
then you become a border
patrol agent.
And rather than ask you what
led to that I'm just going
to read a couple
lines from your book.
You write, "When I was in school
I spent all this time studying
international relations,
immigration, border security.
I was always reading,"
this is your talking
to Beto, your fellow agent.
He asked you why you joined
the border patrol when you did.
"I was always reading
policy and economics,
looking at complex academic ways
of addressing this big
unsolvable problem.
When I made the decision
to apply
for this job I had the idea that
I'd cease things in the patrol
that would somehow unlock
the border for me, you know?
I thought I'd come up with
all sorts of answers."
Do you remember that
conversation with Beto?
I'm sure you do because
you wrote it.
>> Francisco Cantu: Yeah and I
really - that conversation comes
after I'd been doing
the job for a while.
And I think that
conversation is very different
than the conversation I had
with my mom, who was horrified
that I was joining
the border patrol.
When I first told her
she thought I was crazy
and was basically did everything
she could to convince me not to.
And I think by the time I was
having this conversation you
know I had been doing the job
for three years or something
and a lot of the
naiveté had worn off
about the idea of
getting answers.
>> Tom Gjelten: So when
you began did you have any
preconceptions about the
border patrol being you know,
charitable, being kind
of adversarial, neutral?
I mean what kind of
attitudes towards the border,
towards immigrants, towards
undocumented people did
you bring?
>> Francisco Cantu: So I had
a liberal arts education.
And I sort of understood
the border patrol.
I felt like I was going into
this lion's den and I was going
to be kind of you know that
I was going to have to be
in disguise because my
politics didn't align
with what I imagined a lot of -
I kind of imagined I would be
working with all these people
who kind of signed up to
like kick Mexicans
out of the country.
But you know what
I saw when I showed
up at the training
academy is that half
of my classmates were you know
Mexican, Mexican American.
They were from the
border region.
And I think still you
know just under half
of the border patrol
is Hispanic.
And a lot of them have
undocumented people
in their family.
And a lot of people they
grow up in these border towns
where if you look at who
owns a house, who owns a car,
who is doing well, who is able
to provide for their family,
it's people that are in law
enforcement or it's people
who are you know involved
somehow with the cartel.
And so for a lot of these
people it's a very easy choice.
It's not this big
conflicted choice.
But you know for
me I looked at it
as an extension of my education.
I had just finished the
international relations degree
focusing on the border
and you know I imagined
that I would do this work
for three or four years
as like a graduate degree and
that I would be able to go
and have like all these answers
had alluded everybody else
and that I'd be able to
go into politics or policy
or become an immigration lawyer.
And I just have this whole
you know, bag of tricks,
but it wasn't like that at all.
I left with more questions
than I joined with.
>> Tom Gjelten: We'll get
into some of those questions.
Alfredo did you have a
- what was your opinion
of the border patrol experience
as a young man in El Paso?
>> Alfredo Corchado: In El Paso
we had a small little restaurant
called Freddy's Café which
is about three or four blocks
from the international line.
And they were good tippers.
I mean they spent a lot of time.
I didn't realize at the
moment but this was sort
of my early years
as a journalist
and Freddy's was the best
place to go there and sort
of listen to what was going on.
I mean we had some
other people coming
in from Mexico were smuggling,
this was before NAFTA,
so it was a lot more
smuggling back and forth.
And you can kind of listen into
the conversations that was going
on between both sides.
But I remember it
was in the early 90's
when the border patrol,
they were on bikes,
they were with the city police
and they begin asking people
for identity, for
proof of citizenship.
Obviously you felt harassed.
Going to the airport, I remember
one time I had just become a
citizen and so they
took my green card away.
And I became a citizen because
my editor - I was now working
for the Wall Street
Journal in Philadelphia
and my editor felt very
strongly that if I was
to become a foreign
correspondent I should be a
U.S. citizen.
He said it would provide
much more protection.
So I go to El Paso, they
take my green card away
and they just gave me some
paper basically saying I was
in this country legally.
And I think in Philadelphia
the 76ers played a game,
it was a pre-season game in
El Paso but we're leaving,
it's a 5:00 a.m. flight
or something really
early in the morning.
And the border patrol came up
to me and they kept asking.
And at first I felt offended
that they were profiling me.
You're Hispanic, so
they went after me
and kept asking me questions.
And I didn't have a way to
prove my citizenship or the fact
that I was in this
country legally.
And the - I remember I took
out my Dow Jones credit
card, my American Express.
And that's how they
were able to let me go.
And that always kind of
registered and so years later
when my brother said
that he wanted
to become a border patrol agent,
we also sort of begged
him not to.
But my parents, to their
credit they thought
that was a good job.
And so as Francisco was
saying there's a lot
of border patrol
agents who are Hispanic.
A lot of people I know,
people I grew up with
and I think you know you learn
to - not to categorize them.
But they're always, there's to
this day whenever I'm traveling
or whenever my parents
are traveling with me
and my father is still
very much a Durango native.
I mean he still wears his hat.
You know they're
going to stop him
and you know they're going
to ask him questions.
I get very sarcastic
at times and I come in
and I'll speak Spanish
the whole time, [Spanish].
But I realize that it's -
it's still very much that cat
and mouse game that
we grew up with
as little kids on the border.
Today it's a much
more tense time.
And so you try not
to do anything.
I mean you try to just
be as polite as possible.
You don't want to give them
any reason to harass you
and miss your flight
or especially
when you're crossing the border.
I mean I live on the border and
I'm criss crossing all the time.
So you - all that stuff we
used to do five, six years ago.
I mean all that or
maybe right after 9/11,
I mean it's a new
world on the border.
And you try - and you know
that there's no room for joking
around or kidding around.
>> Tom Gjelten: Yeah,
we just saw a story
in the Washington Post last week
that even people who are born
in the United States,
Mexican Americans born
in the United States are
- have to deal with having
to prove their citizenship.
>> Alfredo Corchado: My sister
is an immigration lawyer
and she's been warning
me for months.
She says you know,
"You need to understand
that this is a new
time in America.
This is a different
time in this country."
And they can - I can't
believe I'm saying this here
at the National Book Festival
but anyone can really go back
and look at your records and if
there's any reason to doubt you,
you know, they can - they can
take your citizenship away?
>> Tom Gjelten: Francisco,
when you joined the
border patrol, was it 2012?
Was that when it was?
>> Francisco Cantu: I left
in 2012 actually, 2008.
>> Tom Gjelten: 2008.
So was 2008 a very different
time, was it different
on the border in 2012 than it
was when you joined in 2008?
>> Francisco Cantu:
I think Alfredo talks
about this in his book.
Because I grew up I Arizona
and I think the border
and border enforcement in
Arizona is very different
and was very different at
that time than it had been
in the past in places
like Texas and California.
Because Arizona is sort
of the place where all
of the border traffic has
been funneled over the course
of two decades like
beginning in the early 90's
and then you know, by the time
I joined we were in the middle
of Arizona being - the
Arizona desert being the sort
of you know, this killing
field really of hundreds
of deaths take place
every year in the desert.
So I forgot the original
question,
I just started talking
about Arizona and -
>> Tom Gjelten: That's an
interesting threat talking
about how many times
you're out in the desert
and I think it was illuminating
to me how dangerous it is
for migrants to cross
the desert.
My original question was did the
border have a different feeling
in 2008 from 2012?
>> Francisco Cantu: I guess
what I call attention to that
because sort of the
cat and mouse game.
It exists but it's very
different because the stakes -
the area where I was
working was so remote.
And so you know the feeling,
it was - I joined right
as the election of
Barack Obama happened.
And so it was this
transition time.
Like I came in at the tail end
of the George Bush hiring push.
And you know the
border patrol academy
where I was trained was just
turned into this factory
to pump border patrol
agents out into the field.
The size of the border
patrol you know I don't know
if it doubled but there
was thousands and thousands
of agents from you know
after 9/11 to 2008.
>> Tom Gjelten: And what
would be a typical night
or day particularly
in the early period
when you're a border
patrol agent.
What were you doing?
>> Francisco Cantu: You
know you - what's incredible
about the border patrol is
how quickly you are turned
to work on your own.
And you know because -
because you're patrolling
such vast amounts of space.
You know you don't work
with partners unless something
happens and then you say okay,
like I've got - I'm
tracking a group and may call
in some backups so that I
can work this with somebody.
But you're often alone.
You're often - it's often
very boring, you know like 80%
of the job is boredom.
You're literally driving
in a car back and forth
on dirt roads looking
for foot prints.
And there's also depending on
what kind of agent you are,
you're also outside a lot.
You're out in the desert
a lot and it's very -
for all of the technology
that exists on the border,
for all of the militarization
that has happened there,
the bread and butter of border
patrol work comes down to
like tracking, you know
following footprints.
>> Tom Gjelten: You talk about
always looking for a sign.
>> Francisco Cantu: Right.
Yeah we call it foot sign.
And so you know in the area
where I worked it was -
there was a lot of
drug trafficking.
It was maybe half and half, but
you know we were sort of trained
to let - to just seize the
drugs and not arrest people
because it's all this paperwork.
You find out like how much -
how lazy - how lazy people are.
And how - you know
like bureaucracy -
>> Tom Gjelten: You're
talking border patrol agents -
>> Francisco Cantu: Everyone.
I mean in like bureaucracy
breeds a certain kind
of indifference.
And you see that happening on
the job and then you realize
like that you're dealing
with human beings.
And there's a certain amount
of callousness that is part
of the culture of that job.
That you know, it's sort of
infiltrating and normalized.
It's being normalized
for young recruits.
You come into the field and the
people who are training you are
like "Okay we got these drugs.
We're not going to go
chase after these people.
They'll probably make it."
You're in the middle of
nowhere, like you're miles
from any paved road where
anybody would be driving.
And they're like
okay, these people,
they'll make their way
out into the desert.
But then what you realize when
you see the bigger picture is
that those people
are often dying.
You know they've been scattered,
they've left all their food
and water and so there's a lot
of disconnect, that's happening
and is being passed
along to these agents.
>> Alfredo Corchado: I
was just going to add.
I used to see a lot when
we worked in the fields
in California there was a
lot of cynicism on our part
about the border patrol.
Because they would
usually show up right
as the season was
going to end, you know?
And we would all cry
[Spanish], but they were there
and you know this was August,
the sugar beet season was
about to end and it
was time to leave.
And so you would have
the border patrol come in
and sometimes it was a free ride
back to Tijuana or something.
>> Francisco Cantu: Yeah
and also the fiscal year
for the government ends in
September; so it's a good way
to get the numbers up.
>> Tom Gjelten: So
meanwhile Alfredo,
let's go back to Philadelphia.
You begin as a journalist in
El Paso, then you get a job
with the Wall Street Journal
and you go to Philadelphia.
You have a pretty
boring assignment,
as I recall you're covering
quarterly earnings and so forth.
But one of the things
that caught my attention
because you know we're
accustomed to hearing
so much Spanish around us,
even watching you know is
when you moved to Philadelphia
you felt pretty isolated
as a Hispanic, generally
specifically
as a Mexican American.
Granted you used to follow the
janitors into the restroom just
to hear them speak
Spanish because you were
so lonesome for hearing Spanish.
>> Alfredo Corchado: Right,
when I - before I left
for Philadelphia I called
several people in El Paso
and I said, "Do you
know anyone in Philly?"
And one of them said there's
- this was a union leader
in El Paso said "There's a guy
named [Inaudible] Rodriguez
who is a human rights activist
and he might be the only Mexican
in the whole region;
so be nice to him."
And he gave me the number.
This is before social media.
So I remember I called
him and called him
and he finally answered
the phone, "Bueno?"
And I thought, okay
I'm in Heaven.
And that's really -
that's how we met.
It was [Inaudible] and I, we
meet at an Indian restaurant,
right near the University
of Pennsylvania.
I think after our
third meeting we said,
there's got to be something
- we loved Indian food,
but there's got to be something
closer to Mexican food.
Even if - and he
said there's a write
up in the Philadelphia
Enquirer about a restaurant
that just opened up,
and it's Mexican.
And I thought it's probably part
of that Chi Chi's
chain or something.
But we were so desperate
that we made it to Tequila's,
the restaurant was Tequila's.
And it was on Locust Street
and it was that night -
a wintery night in Philadelphia
where we met these
four other Mexicans.
And it was at that moment that -
>> Tom Gjelten: These
are the characters?
>> Alfredo Corchado: These
are the main characters,
[Inaudible] who ends up
becoming a Tequila connoisseur
and now he's in [Inaudible]
and the restaurant.
He probably has the best
Mexican restaurant -
>> Tom Gjelten: Tequila's
still exist.
>> Alfredo Corchado:
Tequila's still exist.
In fact it expanded.
A second guy [Inaudible]
at the time just graduated
from the University of
Pennsylvania and ran
for mayor a couple years ago.
He has probably a
future as mayor.
He dropped out.
His mother was very
ill and later died
and obviously [Inaudible]
Rodriguez.
But I thought these four
characters could sort
of help tell the story
that's been told forever,
a story about immigration.
But for me in telling the story
through these four
people I was really trying
to tell the larger story.
And the person who
really inspired me more
than anything was my father
and his generation
of bracero workers.
How do I tell that story?
How do I tell the
bigger story at a time
when Mexican migration
has really slowed down.
I mean you hear a lot
about the invasion coming
from the south, from Mexico.
Mexican migration is
at an all-time low.
And people in my
father's generation,
bracero generation
they're in their 70s, 80s,
90s most of them - a
lot of them are dying.
So that was really my way to try
to tell this bigger
story is friendship
and the backdrop you have
the biggest migration shift
in the United States.
>> Tom Gjelten: Right, and you
really over these last 30 years,
you've really sort of
explored your dual identity.
There's a line here that I love.
[Inaudible] and his
restaurant I think you ask him
if he has nachos or
something like that.
And he says [Spanish].
I can't translate that because
this is going to be archived.
But basically he's saying
no way do I have nachos,
that's like dirty Tex Mex food.
>> Alfredo Corchado:
This was from his menu
and it said Nachos [Inaudible].
>> Tom Gjelten: That's
what it was, yeah.
He's obligated to have nachos.
And then he says to you that's
just dirty Tex Mex food.
Do you remember what
you said to him?
Maybe it was - it
might have been Primo.
"I wasn't so sure how to defend
that other than remind him
that Tex Mex is not so different
from what we were
becoming at table 21.
Something else that wasn't
soley Mexican anymore."
>> Alfredo Corchado:
Right, right.
>> Tom Gjelten: So you
begin to see yourself sort
of in an analogous
way to Tex Mex food.
>> Alfredo Corchado: Tex Mex
food and I would also say
that it was Philadelphia,
because it was Tequila's we -
at the end of the day we ended
up becoming more Mexican.
I think more Mexican than I
would have become on the border
or in El Paso because it gave
us a much more of an identity.
And the nostalgia
obviously played a big role,
the music and yes, the Tequila.
I mean it - I mean when we met
about a year ago we had a 30
years reunion and we met -
and we looked at one another.
And it was Primo
who looked at us
and said "Aren't you
glad you made the move?
You would never have been as
Mexican as you are today."
And I thought that was -
>> Tom Gjelten: Well
in your book,
and Primo is the Human
Right's activist.
David is the restaurant
owner and you have a section
in your book where David's son
is there and Primo tells him,
I'm going to read this for you
that his father David has
built his own Mexico here
in Philadelphia.
He doesn't need to
be back in Mexico.
He lives in the Mexico he has
built for himself and for us,
a Mexico more real than
the one he left behind
which is what you're saying.
>> Alfredo Corchado: And the
context of that was right
after - right after the
election in 2016 there was a lot
of debate, especially
with David and myself
as to whether we would stay
in the United States
or go back to Mexico.
And so his son was
incredibly fearful
that his father would
actually move
to [Spanish] where he's from.
And so there was
all this debate.
Dave had just become a
father and he kept sort
of imagining his father
and his son growing
up without a grandfather.
And so that was this
big debate going on.
Do we go back to Mexico or
do we stay in this country?
We ended up staying.
But as David says you know we
don't really have to choose,
because he's [Inaudible] in
Philadelphia and the same thing
with me going back and forth.
>> Tom Gjelten: Francisco,
the Mexicans
that you were encountering as
a border patrol agent there -
the experience of coming to this
country is a really traumatic
experience because you're
dealing with the ones
who are coming illegally.
And you talked about
the disconnect
that many border patrol
agents feel from the lives
of the people that they
are monitoring or tracking.
Did you feel that yourself?
There are certainly moments
where you are really connecting
with these people and then
you find yourself sort
of forgetting their names
or - you know what was it
like to sort of connect with
them and then disconnect?
>> Francisco Cantu: You
know I think a big theme
of this book is how institutions
are built often in a way
that dehumanizes the
people that they deal with.
And so you know I think
that disconnect comes
from the training
that you're given
and the border patrol academy.
You're taking people who
they have this background,
they have this connection
often with these people
but then you step into this
academy and you know it's much
like military, law
enforcement, any military
or law enforcement
training where you're kind
of like breaking down
someone's sense of who they are
and where they come from
and you're rebuilding them
in the image of this
enforcement agent.
And so I think you know
you are being trained
that the people you're
encountering are criminals,
and you're being trained
that the encounters
that you're having are criminal
encounters and at any point
like this person could
pose a threat to you,
which you know I understand
why that has to be the training
because you're dealing with
drug trafficking as well.
But the reality of that is when
you're in that job you know most
of the time when you're
encountering somebody,
that's a humanitarian encounter,
it's not a criminal encounter.
You're encountering someone
at least where I worked
in the deserts of Arizona,
you're encountering people
who are lost, who haven't
had food or water for days.
And at the same time that's
being normalized because -
because it happens every day.
And so I think it can
be really challenging
to people develop these
defense mechanisms
where they push away the part
of that - the like human part
of themselves, the part of
themselves that is compassionate
and that would you know feel
empathy for these people,
because you have to wake up
the next day and do it again.
And you're sending these
people back to the places
that they've risked
their lives to flee.
And so I think that began
to take a toll on me
and that's ultimately why I left
and why I began writing
this book is
because it was you know
you realize all the things
that have become normal to
you and but that's not normal,
and you don't want
that for your life.
And you don't want to become
calloused, and you don't want
to become disconnected from
the humanity of these people
and so you know for me I thought
that leaving the border patrol
was you know the separation
from that and that I had kind
of done my work to move past
that part of my identity but
it was really this encounter
that you mentioned, with
somebody that I worked
with years after I
left the border patrol
who wasn't documented
and was deported
and because I had
become friends with him
and because I knew the
inside of this system,
I sort of helped his family
navigate the deportation
process, brought his kids to
see him in court and in jail.
And that was the first time
that I saw behind the other side
of this immigration
deportation complex
that we are seeing right now
and actually talking
about right now.
But you know seeing it
and seeing how it affected
somebody I cared about,
somebody's family.
And seeing how profoundly
borders can be this
violent thing.
Because I think Alfredo and
I we both have a lot of love
for living on the border.
It's this region; it's
this culture that we love.
But for so many people even if
they live in Washington D.C.
or they live in the Midwest
when they get deported
the border is being thrust
into their lives again, and it's
also being thrust into the lives
of their kids and
their family members.
>> Tom Gjelten: I'm going
to give you a chance
in the audience to ask some
questions now and it seems
to me an obvious way to go here.
Is these experiences that
you write about are happening
in a particular political
moment when the border is a word
that we hear used in a discourse
all the time in border policy
and immigration policy
are so front and center.
And so I'm guessing that
some of you have questions
about the wall, about
immigration policy,
etc. So we got about
10 minutes left here.
You ma'am.
>> Hi my name is Lila Hernandez;
I work at American University
and once an Eagle,
always an Eagle.
I wondered if either of you
two had the same experience
that I had growing
up on the border.
I grew up in Michelin and in the
90s we teenagers would just go
to Renosa to go dancing and
clubbing every Friday night.
And I know that a lot of
serious things are happening
on the border and do
happen on the border.
But did any of you
have those experiences
when you were teenagers.
>> Alfredo Corchado: I grew
up at the Kentucky Club
in [Inaudible] and I mean
yeah, it was our life as -
I went to school at UTEP
and community college
so really it was friends
it was just on and on,
I mean the [Inaudible] and that
is one of the hardest things
as a border resident to see
if how we've just sort of left
that behind and how
we - I mean I talked
to young generations
today of people
and they have no idea
what this is all about.
>> Tom Gjelten: So
young people growing
up in El Paso now don't go back?
>> Alfredo Corchado: They
don't go back as much.
I mean some do, but not what
the - not in the same numbers
when I was growing up.
>> Francisco Cantu: And when
I was young and in college
and really sort of
falling in love
with the border you know it
was a place that was so fun
and joyous and full
of so much life.
And you know then having
the experience of working
in the border patrol,
you know which is
in so many ways this
very violent job
and you're seeing things
through this very violent lens.
That's been a really
hard thing for me
because I also see the ways
that we through our policy
and through our rhetoric
and through our discourse
we have turned the border
into this place that
is to be feared.
And we have you know, we are
constantly othering the people
that are on the other
side of it.
We're constantly othering
even the region itself that is
in the United States as if
you know, when you hear a lot
of politicians talk about the
border, they're talking about it
as this sort of wasteland,
this disposable landscape.
And it's - but it's a place
that I love and it's a place
that the culture you know,
predates the border being there.
And I think that was a very
hard journey for me because -
and it's also very
hard as a writer
and I know Alfredo has this
problem too where you want
to capture, you want
to communicate how
grave this situation is
and how you know the
stakes of it for the people
who are crossing the border.
And you know the violence
that exists on the border
and on the other side.
But you also want to
capture it; you don't want
that to be the only thing that
you represent about the place.
You also want to capture
the joy and the love
and the culture and
pride in that.
And so I think that's
part of our challenges
as people writing about -
>> Alfredo Corchado: And really
the co-dependency on both sides.
One side doesn't thrive
without the other.
I think that's something like El
Paso has realized over the years
that you can't turn
your back to place
like [Inaudible]
because of violence.
I think Tijuana and San Diego
try to do that and they realize
in the end you know, you're
connected and you have
to be a solution for both sides.
I mean it's - I don't want to
scare people about the border,
but the U.S. side of the border
today it's - they represent some
of the safest communities
anywhere in the United States.
On the Mexican side you
still have the ups and downs,
the flows etc. But on the U.S.
side it's not just a beautiful
place, not just a great place,
but it's also a very safe place.
>> Tom Gjelten: You ma'am.
>> Thanks for this discussion.
Most of this is focused on
the Mexican U.S. relationship
and I just wanted to know
if you have any reflections
about the other people coming
through the borders whether the
Central Americans, Hondurans,
Guatemalans, everyone else?
What are some of the
experiences and reflections?
>> Tom Gjelten: Did you run
across very many
Central Americans?
>> Francisco Cantu:
In the time that I was
in the border patrol it
was still primarily people
from Mexico but we were
beginning to see that shift.
You know I think what's
important to keep in mind
about because now Central
America migration has overtaken
Mexican migration as Alfredo
mentioned, Mexican migration is
at one of the lowest
points it's ever been.
And Central Americans
have you know,
they are crossing the border -
the undocumented crossings are
primarily Central American now.
This year I think
was the first year
that happened, that
switch happened.
But I think the thing that's
important to keep in mind is
that those - the people
who are crossing the border
from Central America have
already endured this grueling
crossing through Mexico.
The Guatemalan Mexico
border is very dangerous;
the U.S. is sending
a lot of money
to help militarize that border.
And training Mexican
officials and so these people,
you know the minute that
they leave their doorstep
in El Salvador, Guatemala
like their bodies
are being commodified
by the trafficking
organizations that are profiting
by moving them through
the interior of Mexico.
You know the constant
subject of threats by gangs
and law enforcement throughout
the duration of that journey.
So when they get to the United
States I mean that's just sort
of when they get to the
U.S. border that's just the
next step.
And I think we forget that.
And I think that we forget that
these people are really refugees
and I think that we've
sort of dirtied that word
in our discourse in this country
like we're using refugee
as this dirty word.
But you know growing up
like you recognize refugees
as the most vulnerable
population that you know
that we have an obligation to
you know help these people.
[ Applause ]
>> Hi. My name is
Maria and I also grew
up on the border region
actually in Edinburgh.
So shout out to whoever
was from [Inaudible].
And my question is how do
you deal with your identity -
I often feel like
most [Inaudible].
And then my other question
is with militarization
of the border what is your view
on the violation of privacy
of citizens in the
border regions.
>> Alfredo Corchado: I arrived
in Mexico - Mexico City in 94
and that really felt
[Inaudible].
I think -
>> Tom Gjelten: Neither
here nor there.
>> Alfredo Corchado: You had
to claim one or the other.
I think those feelings are
really - have really changed.
I mean I find that
Mexico has become a much,
much more accepting.
Obviously the United
States is going through -
there's a lot of diversity.
So it's that sense of
seamless where I go to Mexico.
I'm in Mexico City and all I
hear is English from Mexicans.
I come to the United States
and it's the same thing.
I feel - I don't feel that
sense of machismo anymore.
I'm not a [Inaudible] anymore.
[Inaudible].
And that's - I mean that
was the thing that I wanted
to come across in this book.
In Mexico [Inaudible], but
it's really coming together.
School children in Mexico are
now required to learn English
and speak English; so those -
I mean I'm responding
to you as a Mexican.
Because when I was over there
I would get all this crap you
know, you were - you
betrayed us and so forth.
Those feelings are largely gone.
>> Tom Gjelten: We have
literally one minute left
quick questions.
>> Okay I spent some time
on the border this summer
doing humanitarian aid work
and Francisco if you could
speak to the relationship
between border patrol and
humanitarian aid workers.
Because I witnesses border
patrol destroying humanitarian
aid supplies in the
desert in Arizona.
>> Francisco Cantu: Thank
you for mentioning that.
There's a case that everyone
should be paying attention
to right now where humanitarian
aid worker his name is Scott
Warren, was arrested
by the border patrol.
There was long, at least
under Obama there was sort
of this uneasy peace
between the two sides.
And now under the new
administration humanitarian aid
workers are being arrested
and charged with littering
by leaving water
out in the desert.
And so it's a really
important case
and I think you know
criminalizing humanitarian aid
is you know, I think it's really
unforgiveable and I think that -
[ Applause ]
And the last thing I'll say
because we're out of time is
that I think you know sort of
up to us to maintain outrage
at the border patrol
slashing water bottles
or dumping water bottles.
We all saw - maybe we didn't
all see it but there's a video
that went around
and become viral.
And we keep forgetting
that's happening
and then a video comes
out and we remember.
And I think we have to sustain
our outrage at those practices
and hold these institutions
accountable
so that change will happen.
[ Applause ]
>> Tom Gjelten: The
Line Becomes a River:
Dispatches from the Border.
Alfredo Corchado, Homelands
Four Friends, Two Countries
and the fate of the great
Mexican American migration.
Thanks to you.
>> Alfredo Corchado: Thank you.
[ Applause ]